it's 11:40 I guess we can get started
hello and welcome to clean architecture
with ASP net cord 2 - I'm Jason Taylor
and I'm an SSW solution architect you
can find me on Twitter at Jason G tau or
on my blog Korean flow net I try to blog
once a week so the contents nice and
fresh a last blog at NDC Sydney 2018 in
September so not quite reaching that but
I'm going to improve someone from my
companies came to me last week and said
would it be ok if you blog once a month
and I said yeah that's that's fine I try
to blog once a week so I think I can
achieve once a month I've been a
developer now for 19 years and I've
learned the most important principle is
kiss or keep it simple stupid and this
principle states that systems should be
kept simple rather than made more
complicated and today I'm going to show
you the simplest approach to building
enterprise applications with clean
architecture and this is the simplest
approach because what I build is not
simple or trivial I build medium to
large to complex applications so you
could definitely do things differently
in something that's simple and trivial
but that's not what this is about
this is about enterprise application
development let's get started with clean
architecture the domain and the
application layer are at the center of
the design this is known as the core of
the application now in the domain we
have enterprise logic and types and in
the application layer we have business
logic and types the difference being
that the enterprise logic could be
shared across multiple systems whereas
the business logic will exist only in
this system now rather than have core
depending on concerns such as data
access and persistence we invert these
dependencies so infrastructure
persistence and presentation all depend
on core this is achieved by adding
abstractions or interfaces inside of
core which are then implemented by
layers outside of core a good example is
the repository pattern so if we wanted
to implement the repository pattern in
this design then
an irepository inside of core which is
implemented then maybe as EF core or
[ __ ] in the persistence layer now with
with this design all dependencies flow
inwards and core has no dependencies so
infrastructure of persistence and
presentation depend on core but not on
one another and this results in an
architecture and design that's
independent of frameworks core doesn't
need any frameworks to exist it's
testable we can test the logic in that
inside of core without a UI without a
database and without a webserver and
it's easy to test
there aren't any external dependencies
and we know the logics the most
important part of our application so
this is very important it's independent
of the UI we'll have the flexibility to
change the UI easily and that's a good
thing right now we're dealing with a lot
of different web frameworks angular
react view we want to move to the latest
and greatest and we'll be moving to
Blaser so we want that flexibility when
we do move to a new presentation
technology we're not going to impact the
logic inside of core it's independent of
that it's independent at a data base so
right now we might be using sequel
server oracle Postgres but soon we'll be
switching into cosmos DB it's gonna be a
lot cooler when we're building blazer
applications on cosmos DB and finally
it's independent of anything external
core simply doesn't know anything about
the outside world
now with this design you can see that
there's only three layers now you might
need more or you might need less it just
depends on the complexity of your
application the only thing you need to
keep in mind is those dependencies need
to continue to point inwards that's what
gives us the great flexibility and the
high maintainability and that's going to
be the difference between an application
that lasts a few years to an application
that's going to last 20 years so this is
my example Northwind traders show of
hands who's heard of Northwind traders
pretty much everyone Northwind traders
is cool right no one no one thinks north
and traders is cool I might change your
mind so it's now cross-platform I have
upgraded it it runs on Windows Mac and
Linux so that's good
it's dotnet core too too soon oh I
played it two three
EF core two to code first and data
seeded that's cool right Northwind
traders is cool again let's take a look
so this is my Northwind traders solution
you can find it on github I'm gonna
share a link at the end so you don't
need to take note of this but I just
wanted to point out when you go to the
repo there's some nice instructions here
on how to get started and what you'll
need and we can follow along with these
instructions just to get it running I
don't want to show you one thing
initially just how to launch the
application because there are two parts
to it this has an angular front-end and
so to launch the angular front-end we
use we go to the command prompt
Northwind web UI client up and we just
have to run NPM start and that'll launch
the front-end now from the backend we
can just go to the web UI project and we
can just press ctrl f5 and that'll
launch at the backend
if you launch the backend without the
front end running as it is now you'll
see this exception don't be alarmed
sometimes my laptop just needs a little
bit more time to get started so there we
go it's running and if we come here and
launch that's all good
so this is a sample application it does
have some functionality but its purpose
is primarily to demonstrate the
principles of clean architecture and the
key points that I'd like to make in this
presentation it has a nice open API
behind it so you can explore the API and
see some of the functionality and we'll
talk about that a little bit later but I
just wanted to give you a tour of of the
project so I'll zoom in here for you
here we go so you can see the solutions
broken up into a number of folders
correlating to the folders in the
architecture and design I showed you
earlier
there's a docs folder here and that
contains a readme that's the github
readme so you can take a look at that
and then there's the slides from the
presentation so when you do go and have
a look at this you'll have all of the
resources from today now you can see
here I have my core layers application
and domain and inside each of those
they're read miss also so you can get an
understanding at each layer what should
be contained within there I have my
infrastructure layer which contains
infrastructure and persistence I didn't
mention this earlier but persistence
really is a kind of infrastructure we
just separated out because we've got a
few concerns in there that we're going
to encapsulate and so you could separate
out other infrastructure concerns in
this in the same way so if you wanted to
have Northwind security for your
authentication authorization concerns
that will be an appropriate choice I
have a Northwind common project which is
for my cross-cutting concerns and it has
no dependencies any of those other
projects can depend on common it's a
good place for things like string
extensions or date/time extensions
whatever whatever type of thing you
might want to put in there and then you
can see I've got a bunch of tests on
just just to keep it all running nice
and healthily
okay skip through that so key points for
this first section the domain contains
the enterprise-wide logic and types and
that's the logic that we can use in
multiple systems the application
contains the business logic in types and
that's the logic that's specific to this
application infrastructure including
persistence includes all external
concerns and the presentation and
infrastructure depend only on
application not on each other
so infrastructure and presentation
components can be replaced with minimal
effort and that's because we're not
going to affect call and we do that it
has no external concerns so now we're
going to have a look at the domain layer
followed by every other layer in
application and essentially in this talk
I'll make some key points I'll highlight
the things that I think are important so
that you get a good understanding of the
project but you'll also want to dive in
and take a look for yourself because
there's a lot more going on then I can
include in the time allowed in this talk
so inside of the domain layer we have
entities value objects enumerations
logic and exceptions let's take a look
so the first key point that I'd like to
make is regarding the use of data
annotations so you can see what I have
here is an entity called customer and
it's nice and clean
but if I look at the history we can
actually find a version that includes
data annotations here we go so this is
another version but I'll make it I'll
make that much bigger for you let's go
150 there we go so this version contains
data annotations and and in the past
earlier versions of EF we used to use
data annotations all the time
and they had two purposes and that was
to instruct the ORM how to create the
relational model and also to provide
validation but in newer versions of the
F core it doesn't do the validation
anymore you can use dart annotations for
validation it's just not something that
you have courses are for and it also it
does still use it for relational
modeling but there's a much better way
to do that we can we can actually use
fluent API configuration instead and
that means that we can keep our entities
nice and clean and looking like this
because really those sort of concerns
don't belong in our domain layer anyway
we want to keep that into the
infrastructure layer specifically in the
persistence project now the next point
that I'd like to make we can we can use
this example again is to initialize all
collections and also to make the private
the set as private or to remove them all
together and you might think well why
will I do that and it it's just because
it makes life easier if we do that we
don't need to think when we're accessing
a new customer object we don't need to
say hmm I wonder if the order collection
has been initialized all right an if
statement if customers orders equals
null then initialize the orders
collection we don't have to do that
anymore
and we gain control of the object it's
it's about helping your developers in
ensuring that they fall into the pit of
success we make it easy for them to do
the right thing and hard for them to do
the wrong thing
so the next one that I want to talk
about is when you're designing your
system let me just see I want you to
think about this this entity we often
use primitive types where where we
shouldn't be using primitive types so
here we have an ad account and its type
is string and that's fine ad accounts
are strings but not all strings are
valid ad accounts the certain rules in
the way that ad accounts will be created
the value and there's certain ways in
which we'll use the ad account for
example sometimes we'll want just the
domain name and sometimes we'll want
just the username and sometimes we'll
want to roll together in some kind of
display format now that's logic there's
validation and logic associated with
using this ad account now if we don't
find somewhere to encapsulate this
that's going to be problematic that in a
large system that logic is going to
appear time and time again because new
developers experience developers may not
know about it so we need a good way to
encapsulate that logic in a complex type
and that's where value objects can
really help so you can see here I've
changed it to a value object and let's
take a look at the implementation
actually let's take a look at the tests
okay so I have this ad account and it
should have the correct domain and name
so I can construct it using this factory
method and all I have to do is pass in
the ad account string and then I'll have
access to the domain and the name so
that's nice and easy I won't have to
write logic around that I've got a
method to string which I've overridden
and it returns the correct format so we
can see that if I construct a new object
it's going to return the format which
will essentially be SSW slash jason the
original format i have an implicit
conversion operator so i can take an ad
account type and implicitly convert it
to a string which is great for whatever
purposes i need in the string format
logging is one that comes to mind i have
an explicit conversion operator so i can
directly cast from a string to an ad
account
and I control the creation of the ad
object if the ad account is not valid
the ad account string it doesn't contain
a slash then that's going to fail and
and it brings me to my next point which
is to use custom domain exceptions this
exception ad account invalid exception
will be a lot easier to debug than the
index out of range exception that would
otherwise be throw on I have a quick
look at the implementation so you can
see here it has a private constructor
I'm controlling the construction of this
object through the factory method
it essentially splits the string into
two parts and this is where it could
throw an index out of range exception so
I catch any exceptions and just say hey
there's something wrong with this ad
account so that's much better I have
this type it encapsulates all the logic
associated with it and I don't have to
worry about logic appearing elsewhere
when my developers use this type they're
going to fall into the pit of success
again they're not going to think about
how do I get just the domain part how do
I think get just the name part so when
you're building your entities just think
about this property that I'm creating is
it really a string or is it more complex
than that will I have logic associated
with it
is it a primitive type or is it a
complex type
okay so key points for the domain layer
avoid using data annotations there are
better ways they clutter up our domain
and we'll see that soon the better
approach use value objects where
appropriate I mentioned before just
think about it is it really a primitive
type or is it more complex initialize
all collections and privates and use
private setters help your developers to
fall into the pit of success and create
custom domain exceptions so much easier
to debug than an index out of range
exception so now we're going to look at
the application layer the application
layer contains interfaces models view
models and DT OS logic commands and
queries we'll talk about that soon and
validators and again custom exceptions
so CQRS we all know by now CQRS stands
for command query responsibility
segregation and with CQRS we separate
our reads from our rights and the
benefits include maximizing performance
and scalability and that's awesome
but for me the most important benefit is
simplicity i find that when i use CQRS
everything becomes easier it's easy to
add new features because I can just add
a new query or command and it's easy to
maintain our changes should be nicely
isolated to a single query or command
and so we're less likely to introduce
bugs now if you like CQRS then you'll
love using CQRS with mediator they like
the perfect couple
so with mediator we don't define our
commands and queries as requests so the
application layer just becomes a series
of requests response objects and with
that we get the fantastic ability to
introduce additional behavior so we can
add functionality before and/or after
each request so behavior such as
cross-cutting concerns such as logging
cache invalidation and security become
easier because we're using mediator we
get this really nice pipeline which is
powerful so let's take a look
okay so you can see here in their
application layer I've separated things
by feature so everything related to
customers is in this customers folder
and there's only two things there's
commands and queries if we expand those
it's really obvious what everything in
those folders will do we know that if we
go into here it will be a create
customer command and if we come into
here that will be where we can work with
our get customers list feature and
that's a query let's take a look at this
one inside of this folder I have
everything that I need to work on this
feature I don't have a separate folder
for my view models I don't have a
separate folder for my DTO so I don't
have a separate folder for my handlers
so when I'm ready to change this feature
it's all here I don't have to jump
around to find what I'm looking for now
with mediator we define our commands
enquiries as requests so you can see in
this case this is a DTO
for getting a list of customers at the
moment it doesn't have any properties
but I might start to add some so I might
say things like page size filtering
abilities what page that I'm currently
on but with with the mediator framework
we define these as type I requests and
then the return type so this query will
return our customers list view model if
we jump in here and look at the handler
we can see it's quite simple we're
injecting an eye Northwind dbcontext
and a mapper for our mapper and we're
simply constructing a new customers list
view model and this is this is a very
nice approach because what's contained
within here are only the things needed
to return this query we don't have a
large service that's responsible for
many things which becomes hard to
navigate it's a single file with a
single purpose
you can see the create customer command
is quite simple also
so this is our DTO it's a requester as
well it doesn't return anything so we're
not specifying that here and it contains
everything that we need to go ahead and
create a customer now I've taken a
slightly different approach here I've
actually nested the handler inside the
command and that can help to improve
discoverability we'll talk about that a
little bit later you can see again it's
quite straightforward essentially I'm
creating a new customer entity I'm
adding that saving the changes and
publishing a customer created event and
then with mediator I can create handlers
that have specific functionality for
that event as well the next thing I want
to talk about is validation so we
mentioned that data annotations are not
so good at the domain level well I think
they're not so good at this level also
data annotations are ok we can use them
for simple validation scenarios but not
so much for complex validation scenarios
for that I prefer to use fluent
validation and let me let me show you an
example so here I have an update
customer command and it just has the DTO
to an updater customer and then I have
an update customer command validator so
with the fluent validation I'm able to
define the validation rules using a
fluent syntax in a separate file and
these rules are obviously simple there
are there no more complicated than what
you can support with data annotations
but down here I have a couple of example
more complex rules so you can see here I
have a rule for the postal code when the
country is equal to Australia then the
post code should match this regular
expression essentially it should be four
digits and if not it will return this
error Australian post codes have four
digits so that's not much more
complicated but it is a nice syntax we
can do that with data
patience but we also have this one we
have a rule for the foreign it must have
a Queensland landline when the country
is equal to Australia and the postcode
starts with four so in this case we're
actually looking at Crossfield
validation and we can do a lot with with
fluent validation in this way really we
take full control of the validation
scenarios and so the implementation is
up to us yes question I'm not validating
domain entities I'm validating other
commands or queries the requests to the
application so this is kind of the first
line of defense because everything's
coming in as a request so what was that
no no it's in it's in the application
layer I like to have the things that
change together together and so the the
command and the command validator sit
together so that when I need to update
that feature it's easy to access those
things I prefer not to have to jump
around okay so one of the other things
about using mediator I mentioned as we
get that pipeline and so to run these
validators I have what's called a
pipeline behavior and if we look at this
this is a request validation behavior so
remember everything that's coming into
this application is a request and I have
a pipeline behavior which handles these
requests so the requests might be of
type create customer command or get
customer detail query if there are
validators associated with those
commands or queries this little process
here will run them and if there are
exceptions it will return a validation
exception so that's a custom exception
that was thrown from the application
layer so that means the request
validation is automatic the developers
don't need to think about that if they
associate a validator with her
Qwest then it will be validated and
that's great that's a part of the
mediators our pipeline so here we have
another simple behavior this is an I
request preprocessor so it happens
before the request runs in mediator and
it's quite simple essentially we get a
request let's say create customer
command I take the name of that request
and I just log it using dotnet cause
built in logging abstraction so I just
say Northwind request create customer
command and then I take the actual
request DT Oh everything that's in the
create customer command and I serialize
that so that's going to be available in
the log and then finally I have another
one which is just a simple request
performance behavior and so this one is
a pipelined behavior like the validator
so with this one I start a timer I
complete the complete the request get
the response and stop the timer and if
the request happens to take greater than
500 milliseconds then I log a warning to
the database in much the same way as I
was logging the information so that's
kind of that's kind of great any request
that comes into the system with a few
lines of code I can log that request
I can I can when I add the user details
I'll be able to filter it by user set
the date range and I can see kind of
what they were doing or where they had
the problem and what kind of exceptions
were associated with that and because
the request itself has been serialized I
can take that serialize request and I
can add that to a test that's probably
going to fail because will the customers
complaining and then I can fix it and
the test will pass so that's pretty cool
all right and the other thing that I
wanted to talk about was abstractions so
in this in this layer we have a couple
of abstractions so I have the I
Northwind dbcontext
which is my interface instead of using
the dbcontext directly now this is a
compromise I've chosen to use entity
framework core directly because make no
mistake even though this is an interface
I still need a dependency on entity
framework core in this application now
if I wanted to avoid that
if I had a good reason to use the
repository and unit of work then I would
actually implement those patterns and I
wouldn't need the dependency on energy
framework or but these are some of the
real decisions we make when we build
software today we know the right thing
to do but we make choices based on speed
and cost and quality the other interface
that I have in here is a demonstrator
for I notification service and the
important thing to note is it doesn't
matter where the implementation for the
notification server is services it's
going to be an infrastructure somewhere
but core only depends on this interface
and this message type that's not coming
from infrastructure that's coming from
core as well so I'm sure that if we use
a service like sand grid or something
else it's going to have our own types
and we could easily take a dependency on
that and that would save us time but
that means that we will be tightly
coupled to that framework and when we
want to change to a new messaging
service
we'll have to rewrite those types so
just to avoid that straight away make
sure that the interfaces within core
make sure that the types are worth in
core and do the mapping necessary okay
key points using CQRS and mediator
simplifies your overall design fluent
validation is useful for all validation
scenarios mediator simplifies
cross-cutting concerns we get that
really great pipeline so we can
implement all sorts of things there and
it's independent of infrastructure and
data access concerns all right now we
look at the persistence layer so inside
of the business in layer we have our DB
context because this solutions using
energy framework or we have migrations
configurations seeding abstractions so
here's the big question
used to be a bigger question should we
implement these patterns and I'm going
to answer for you because every time I
ask the question most people say no now
there'll be one or two people who will
say yes but the fact of the matter is
with architecture and design it always
depends now in the general case it's not
always the best choice because you've
core insulates your code from database
changes EF court is an abstraction and
we choose a database provider to work
with that abstraction we can choose
sequel server we can choose Postgres now
we can choose cosmos DB DB context acts
as a unit of work it's implementing that
pattern and the DB set axes are
repository so a common reason for
implementing these patterns with earlier
versions of EF and with other ORM S is
for unit testing but now if core has
features for unit testing without
repositories in the way of the EF core
in-memory provider so that's what I
think but what do the experts think so
Jimmy Bogart who was at the conference
this week he's the chief architect at
head spring and the creator of auto
mapper and mediator which were using in
this solution he says that I'm over
repositories and definitely over
abstracting your data layer so I'd say
I'd say he's against implementing
repositories and unit of work in in in
most scenarios then we have Steve Smith
Microsoft MVP and Regional Director for
almost ten years and he says no you
don't need a repository but there are
many benefits and you should consider it
now I think Steve has been very
diplomatic here I think that if you came
to him and showed him your solution and
you didn't have a repository he'd show
you why you need it so very diplomatic
he says you don't need it but I think
he's kind of on the side of implementing
a repository and next we have John Smith
the author of energy framework core in
action and he says no the unit of the
repository slash unit of work pattern
isn't useful with energy framework core
so even the experts don't agree and what
does that tell us well it's simple as is
the case with all design patterns we
need to think about the problem that
they're trying to solve if if the
pattern if applying the pattern solves
that problem for us then go and head and
implement it if you implement it without
a problem to solve then it just
introduces unnecessary complexity so
same approach or design patterns
okay let's have a look at the
persistence layer
okay so first the point that I'd like to
make is the precision Slayer is
independent of the database insofar as
there is a provider that we can change
to with energy framework core you can
see in this particular application the
provider I'm using a sequel server so I
could change that to Postgres so in that
way it's independent of the database I
have changed this solution to Postgres
in the past and and run it on Linux and
it works quite well we talked about not
using data annotations in the domain
layer so how do we configure the ORM so
that so that it knows how to map from
the object model to the relational model
we use fluent API configurations so in
the fluent API configuration for
customer we define everything that we
need and it's outside of the domain
layer so nice and clean in a separate
file we also can automatically apply
these configurations in our DB contacts
we just need to add this line so model
builder don't apply configurations from
assembly and we just say which which
assembly the configurations are
contained within so this is a new
feature I think it came in in in - -
before that we had to either do it
manually or write our own code to apply
it automatically now the most important
thing with working with any framework
which is conventions base is to
understand the conventions because
that's going to make us more productive
so you can see here I'm configuring the
employee entity but right after about
any of you who know entity framework
well well know that I don't need this
line by convention it will recognize
that an employee entity with an employee
ID or an ID just by itself will be
flagged as energy front by energy
framework as being a key so when you're
working with a conventions based
framework it's important to first
understand
the conventions because that's going to
make it easier for you to to work with
that system you'll be more productive
and you co will be simpler because of it
I can just remove anything like that so
I want to just touch one more time on
the repository pattern so obviously in
this application I've chosen not to
implement it but we should definitely
talk about a good reason as to why we
might implement the repository pattern
so in a complex design we might like to
implement the repository pattern at an
aggregate route so an example in this
application would be an order with order
details and why would we do that well we
would implement the repository at the
order level and not at the order detail
level and in this way we will control
how orders can be created updated and
deleted we'll make it easy to
encapsulate that logic so that our
developers can't go directly to the
order detail where we haven't written
the correct logic around adding updating
and deleting order details directly so
remember with the repository with design
patterns first figure out what the
problem is that you're trying to solve
and then apply the appropriate pattern
okay so key points for the persistence
layer it's independent of the database
using EF call we can switch providers we
use fluent API configuration over data
annotations it's simpler to to wire up
and it keeps our domain free of extra
attributes we prefer conventions over
configuration and when we're working
with a framework that is convention
space we need to understand those
conventions clearly and we should
automatically apply all entity type
configurations we can do it with one
line of code so that way we won't forget
okay next the infrastructure layer so
within the infrastructure it's
essentially our implementations
persistence API clients file systems
email / SMS services the system clock
kind of an important one anything
external so let's have a look in this
demonstration I've kept the
infrastructure layer quite simple I've
got my machine date/time which basically
has a couple of properties it just has
now in the current year any anyone think
why we might want to actually implement
machine date/time and only have core
depend on the interface I'd a time
rather than using date/time directly so
what's that yeah possibly yep
testing yep testing testing is the the
main reason that comes to mind for me so
if we have some logic that we need to
test and perhaps that logic is only can
be tested on a Tuesday well if we're
using date/time now directly well we can
only test that on a Tuesday maybe we can
write some logic in our test to check
that it's a Tuesday and only run but
with an i date/time interface we can we
can mock that out and make sure that
it's a Tuesday another nice advantage
that I came across is that I was able to
switch this out for an implementation
where the end user was able to supply
the day time for the system and this was
used for testers so they could actually
configure the date/time
to test things that were time and date
based so they could advance the system
clock bring her back to the current date
time bring it back in time that was
quite useful too so we have a machine
deck time implementation there and then
I have my ultra fast notification
service responsible for sending
notifications so we saw the I
notification service implementation in
core and this is the side of the
interface in core and this is my
implementation it's superfast but the
messages don't go anywhere okay so no a
point an important point to make about
the infrastructure layer is that no
layers should depend on infrastructure
infrastructure depends on core but we
shouldn't have for example presentation
depending on infrastructure we might
have something in presentation that
wants to send a message for example but
when we do that were actually forced to
write logic in presentation logic to
orchestrate the communications between
presentation and infrastructure in order
to send a message now that's logic that
we can't reuse we want to avoid that we
want to push that logic into core so
that when we change out that
presentation layer we don't have to move
that logic as well so it's an important
point all of the logic that we have for
this application should be carefully
encapsulated within core
okay so key points so the infrastructure
layer contains classes for accessing
external resources such as file systems
web services SMTP and so on it
implements abstractions and interfaces
defined within the application layer and
no layers should depend on
infrastructure so next the presentation
layer so what's in our presentation
layer it's the it's our clients it's the
spa whether we're using angular reactive
view could be just a Web API razor pages
MVC or even web forms let's take a look
so what I want to show you here is
something that helps tie all of this
together we're going to take a look at
the controller's so I have a products
controller and I want to show you a
typical example so this is how
controllers were typically built we
would have a products controller we
would inject the dbcontext directly we
would return entities from the
controller and we would accept entities
in order to to update persistence we
would have lots of logic in here and
generally it would get hard to work with
there's a couple of problems with this
the first one is that the the DB context
the persistence is one of the lowest
levels of our system and the controller
itself is one of the highest levels of
our system so when we bring those two
things together we only have one place
to write our logic and that's in the
controller that's in the actions so
that's not great and as you know there's
lots of problems with returning entities
from controllers and using them outside
of this area for example if we have a
product and it has a collection of
categories and that relinquishes let's
say we're updating a customer and we're
not supposed to update the customers
email address but then someone over
posts and supplies the email address
anyway even though it wasn't on the form
well now they've changed the email
address to their email address they can
reset the customers password take over
the account
so there's lots of issues involved in
doing that so we can control that much
better let's have a look at a newer
version so in this version i started
using CQRS
and with with CQRS in this
implementation I wasn't using mediator I
just added all of the interfaces to the
commands increase that I needed now this
was a lot better I have a lot of kind of
boilerplate here in order to get
dependency injection to wire all that up
for me but when we look at the actions
themselves they're now really simple
they're just one or two lines of code no
longer working with the DB context no
longer encapsulating any logic so even
though is it is it is a great step in
the right direction the logic is now in
its respective command or query so it's
quite simple so minor update here we
started using from services so this is a
nice little attribute with the dotnet
core dependency injection we're
basically saying to dependency injection
to inject this query for us so we don't
have to add all of those commands and
queries so it'll just inject it and we
query dot execute inject the command and
we can execute that nice and simple ok
and this is where we introduce mediator
so with mediator all we need to do is
inject a mediator and it knows where to
find the the handlers that are
associated with a command or query so
then we can just say mediator send this
get all products query or mediated send
create product command so it's nice and
easy but now of course we have the power
of the mediator pipeline so we can do a
lot more with the requests and the
responses that are moving through our
application
I think I'll go to the latest version
now so not too much has changed since we
introduced mediator I've I have a bass
controller where we're using property
injection to get mediators so I don't
need to add anything to the constructor
I can just inherit from this base
controller but you can see it is really
simple this controller doesn't contain
any logic it's it's basically become
infrastructure it just has a single
responsibility for products to turn a
products request into a products
response that's it all of the logic is
elsewhere if we have to switch away from
web api to something like Nancy it's not
really going to be that big a deal one
of the things that I'd like to show you
in the presentation layer is I also have
a filter so when we run validation in
the application layer we throw an
exception if there are validation errors
a validation exception and it's up to
the client how they handle that
exception obviously a console
applications going to handle it
differently to a web application in this
application I've created a simple custom
exception filter and it essentially for
any exceptions that happen it'll catch
it turn it into a bad request and return
the failures back to the client and
that's going to be in a format similar
to model state validation so one point
that I want to make here is that we
should work hard to return well-defined
view models and what do I mean by that
well we could return a product with the
product details in order to edit a
product but we could actually return
much more information than that we don't
want our client to have to make
additional requests so for example when
we're turning in a product view model we
can also return things like edit enabled
or delete enabled so the clients not
forced to make authorization checks to
get the additional information that it
needs
we can encapsulate within the view model
everything that the view needs so that
it's simple for new clients to use that
view model and it's also simple for us
to test we can write a test to see that
the edit button is disabled by testing
the view model directly and that's
something that's inside of core and as
we know core has no external
dependencies so it's very easy to write
tests for core so by encapsulating those
things in the view model we do get great
flexibility in in changing our our
presentation layer in the future the
last point that I want to make in this
in this presentation layer is that we
should use open API with our Web API s
so you can see here I've got an open API
UI so this is the swagger UI and for my
developers they can come and explore
this this API they can learn about the
API and understand how it works so I've
got a customers get all customers here I
can click try it out execute that and I
can I can kind of see the response type
and that sort of thing but I can also
generate code from that because I have
the API specification set up I've
actually used it to generate an angular
client for this application so if I dive
into the angular application I have this
Northwind traders API written in
typescript so this is this this is quite
big I didn't have to write any of this
and I can use this directly so by
implementing open API on on the Web API
we're actually making it easier for our
developers to work with the system and
we'll make it easier to to build
front-end applications in a
microservices architecture I can also
generate c-sharp clients so it can make
it easy to communicate with that with
that microservice if that's my preferred
method
this application is configured to use a
tool called n swag to generate the open
API specification and it actually
happens automatically when I build the
web UI it will build a new specification
and place it here in WWE route
specification JSON and it will also
generate the angular client that you saw
and that's actually using msbuild so n
swag has a nice msbuild package and if
we scroll down in this CS proj I've got
to comment it out at the moment don't
need to it actually just runs n swag
after build and we'll keep that up to
date so I don't have to worry about it
anymore usually with these tools you
have two choices
you can do it when that web applications
running and automatically or you can do
it offline kind of how I'm doing it now
I find it preferable to do it offline
because then I don't run into any kind
of issues relating to authentication or
forgetting to start the web front-end
when I'm trying to generate an angular
client and that sort of thing
okay key points for the presentation
layer so controllers should not contain
any application logic we should
encapsulate that within our commands in
queries we should create and consume
while defined view models we want the
view model to contain everything that
the view needs and open API bridges the
gap between the front end and the back
end I have some recommended resources so
first is the book architect in modern
web applications with asp net kora and
Microsoft Azure so this is by Steve
Smith definitely encourage reading this
don't worry if your stack is in asia or
asp.net core there's a lot of great
value in this book this was the book
that I read that first got me interested
in clean architecture I think it's
actually up to version 2 to now next
book is building micro services so
dotnet micro services architecture for
containerize dotnet applications don't
worry that it says micro services don't
worry that it says Asia and and don't
even worry that it says containers
fact of the matter is there's a lot of
great value in this book even if you're
not building Micra services architecture
there's a lot to learn so definitely
have a read of this book the value
object that I implemented it actually
has an abstract base class behind it and
that's where I got that implementation
so great book and finally couldn't do a
clean architecture presentation without
referring to Uncle Bob's book on clean
architecture so obviously it's a one of
one of the best resources so next steps
thank you for coming to my talk today if
you're keen to learn more please grab
the code in slides you can find it at
bitly Northwind traders and get started
try it for yourself I think you'll find
that this approach is simple to build
and maintain all the way from
development to production thank you
[Applause]